coming up next book tv presents
afterwards an hour-long interview
program where we invite guest hosts to
interview authors
this week tom hayden founding member of
students for a democratic society and
former california state senator talks
about his book writings for a democratic
society
the book collects mr hayden's pieces on
various social and political issues that
he has engaged in since the early 1960s
from his opposition to the vietnam war
to his more recent work on gang violence
mr hayden is interviewed by john weiner
professor of history at university of
california irvine professor weiner's
books include historians in trouble and
give me some truth the john lennon fbi
files
most recently is the editor of
conspiracy in the streets the
extraordinary trial of the chicago aid
for which tom hayden wrote the forward
[Music]
tom you were a writer before you were a
political activist
what was your starting point as a writer
i've always been a writer
one doesn't know
where things begin
but i was
i guess i had some need
to be heard
and the adults the teachers the
authorities weren't listening
to me or to us
so that would have been a starting point
and i guess i found it
easy to learn writing who what when
where why that's the
first paragraph that you're you're
taught
the structure of first paragraph in
journalism
so i went to i took journalism classes
in high school and
we had an underground paper this is in
the 50s it was like it was modeled after
mad magazine okay and and
we had an overground paper which was the
school paper
and and where in the united states are
we in high this is a suburb a suburb of
uh detroit called royal oak
and the big secret which i didn't learn
until a couple of years ago when a
graduate student uncovered it was that
the town
was among the first suburbs and it was
racially sealed as a white suburb by
secret covenant
so
so i was a writer i was a sports writer
because that was what was available and
i liked sports and then i became the
editor of the paper
and uh
i think also i was a non-conformist so
the
non-conformity led me towards
critical journalism and
and also in time towards activism
but uh
if there's something about one's nature
it writing would come first for me not
politics or the rest and
then what what changed your mind about
the kind of writing you wanted to do
what led you to leave the
objective mode of who what why and when
and become the the advocate the
pamphleteer
movement writer well there was no
movement
so with journalism there were two
choices there was you wrote editorials
very pompous
role telling everybody what to think
and then you wrote news which was
objective and uh obviously
there's more than those two choices
but it took some time for me to realize
that so i started to
get interested in interpretive writing
investigative writing that was less than
a
commitment to activism
but i started writing about
activism i went to the
went to the bay area in 1960
and i wrote about the growth of the
student movement there
which completely shocked my
administration back in ann arbor because
they thought that this news would spread
like some kind of contagion
which it did i guess
and then i went to the democratic
convention
here in los angeles and
this is august 1960 yeah and martin
luther king was marching
for a civil rights platform plank
and i went and i interviewed him on the
march
and the effect that it had on me was i
realized that
i was in it for the
ambition for the thomas hayden byline
and he was in it for much deeper reasons
and i think at that point i was i began
thinking about whether i should
stop writing about action but
take action
and and i had an interesting rationale
i thought which was
consistent with being a writer
the the theory was that only by taking
action sometimes
can you create evidence that wasn't
there before
about whether something's going to
happen or not
so keeping yourself out of it
was lessening the possibilities of the
action
taking
place with a positive outcome
and so i thought i'm i'm i'm i'm caught
i this is
to be on the sidelines to be objective
is to contribute
a little more to the establishment
than to the activists
to get involved i risk losing my
critical objective
abilities
so then the question became well how can
i
get involved
fully
and still retain
a certain kind of independence
and i don't think i've moved much beyond
that
position that was 50 years ago 40 50
years ago
yeah jerry brown once told me uh
the the jesuits had this idea of
contemplation
in action
that that was their discipline
that comes close to it sociologists
would call it um
uh
participatory
observation participant observer being a
participant observer
uh i guess you could call it
participatory writing
for a participatory society
but it's it's um
it's not easy to resolve uh and i
noticed that
that in this book of writings going back
over 50 years up till now till iraq
i tend to be more comfortable
being a narrator but my experience in
social movements i feel
gives me an invaluable edge over
observers historians newspaper reporters
because i've been there i am there i've
done that i know what that feels like
and so i have a better
um ability to
evaluate what's going to happen i think
than somebody who has only observed but
it's it's a marginal difference
now your your best known you're best
known in this um let's call it early
period
for the port huron statement which was
kind of the defining document of the
student movement the new left in the
united states but even before the port
huron statement you were you were sort
of a becoming a more engaged writer
right uh
how did that happen and i know you you
the the book has some examples of these
pre-port here on
writing i was sent by students for
democratic society
to the south for 50 bucks a week i lived
in georgia
i was in love
and
she was a civil rights worker for the
ywca
out of austin and um
she too was a writer and and a poet
and so
i think i saw my task as a tom payne
kind of pamphlet here i will observe
people fighting for their lives
risking their lives in
the worst parts of mississippi
and then i'll
publish the pamphlet and i'll
tour northern cities and campuses and
i'll speak about what i've what i've
seen so it was a pamphleteer phase and
and your uh
your book that tom hayden reader has
some examples of your writing from those
early days i wonder if you could ask us
to
if you could read us a sample i think
port huron is more famous um
and i might read you the
the
the first sentence of court here give
you this no there's a strange sense of
um
uh how
unorthodox i was as an advocate
they wanted me to
stir it up a little bit but my first
sentence was
we are people of this generation
bred in at least modest comfort
housed now in universities
looking uncomfortably to the world we
inherit
not exactly the communist manifesto
you can see that that's kind of a
distant writing but people seem to think
that it
did speak for them
now the the the youthful idealism
uh i wrote something in mississippi in
61 that was called uh the student
nonviolent coordinating committee in
action it was about a killing and some
demonstrations but the subtitle
dignity for the enslaved and for us all
so you can see this
robust
romantic
thing but earlier in 61
i wrote a preliminary for the
fort hearn statement and i i can't tell
if it's sophomoric or it's
it's not embarrassing but
it's it's it's um let's go for it it's a
young person's writing what is
desperately needed i think is the person
of vision and clarity
who sees both the model society
and the pitfalls that precede its
attainment
and who will not destroy his vision for
short-run gains
but instead hold it out for all to see
as the furthest
dream and perimeter of human possibility
vision and clarity i sounds great to me
that's right um
and there's one other uh uh
part of this that i thought was
noteworthy
in terms of the
how these movements developed because
they were so different than
the movements that were
built around isms great faith and so on
i am beset by doubt at this point
so perhaps are we all we doubt our
ability to affect change
we doubt our ability to understand
enough
we doubt the validity of time-honored
liberal notions we doubt the right and
wrong of it
and i don't recommend that we banish
doubt
uh
not that there where there's a will
there's a way but i would suggest that
it is possible and necessary to think
and act
provisionally yet strongly
in the midst of our doubts
we must begin to see doubt
not as a reason for inaction
but as a reminder of our fallibility
fantastic i think there's some catholic
influence here i think it's good
so uh thank you very much um
for that reading
the port huron statement 1962 it was
published is that right it was written
it was drafted at the end of 61 it was
circulated in the spring of 62 and it
was
published by mimeographed means for 25
cents a copy
i think in june 62.
this would be four
uh kennedy was assassinated yeah before
civil rights had become quite mainstream
before the march on washington before
the
betty friedan book about women's
liberation
it was still a period that i think of
and anybody that went through it as a
period of that beautiful innocence that
james joyce wrote about in the portrait
of the artist it's really
uh you can't understand the 60s without
understanding this brief
utopian moment well i want to ask you
more about that
moment because the port huron statement
has turned out to be
a incredibly important historical
document if if there is a manifesto of
the student movement of of the first
part of the 60s that's it it was and i
remember when it came out it was just
incredibly um
eloquent and uh
a visionary uh
call on students to move away from
apathy
and doubt
towards
participatory democracy you called it
this is the writing of a very young
person
how are you able to write something so
eloquent and so visionary
at such a young age well i think that
you write differently when you're young
when you're middle-aged and more
experienced when you're old and you're
looking back
and i don't rank them as
more or less important but
yeah this is the writing of
an inspired
uh group of people like myself and
it came from a combination
of uh what we had what we had seen in
terms of the apathy all around us
and the utter apathy of the suburbs from
which we came
versus the um
the bravery and and courage of young
people our age nearly all of them black
in the south
who were standing up and doing something
about their oppression and
and i think it takes that friction you
know between
your surface reality
and what's starting to happen it sparks
a creativity and if it rang true to
people i think it's because
it was simply a
cycling back to the audience
what they already knew or were coming to
know because they were starting to
awaken
it wasn't
a foreign set of ideas
dropped on them
to to learn and study study groups or
something like that and how important
was it that
uh this was a statement of a group not
just of one one
writer
the the value of having one person
principal author
is you get a certain consistency
consistency of tone and style yes which
it definitely has and then and then the
value of uh
a group
is that you get much more buy-in and
participation and a sense of ownership
that this is about us we
we created this vision
the downside of that is
uh it can become more clunky as things
are added i'll tell you a funny example
that that didn't really harm it i i had
uh written
uh in the section on the economy that we
that i had
that we i think was all couched as we
uh
were supportive of small innovative
businesses community businesses
and then my draft would go to a group
that sat around in the grass and and
read and argued and kind of rewrote it
not stylistically but as if it was a
constitutional proposal with amendments
right and so rob burledge who's still
active in healthcare in
new york city and was then the editor of
the student paper in austin texas many
of us were campus editors
uh
he he brought back his group's revisions
of the economic section and said
the amendment number one
is is uh uh
an amendment by brother karl marx to
brother tom hayden's draft on the
economy
can they i forget it really didn't go
beyond uh
you know kind of uh
watered down democratic socialism public
ownership of key assets of the economy
but it eliminated the reference to small
business
very good so
you lose you gain you lose when you
collectivize the writing effort now the
port here on statement didn't just
come out of a political moment it also
came out of a world of writing other
articles other authors you were also an
intellectual as well as an activist who
were the intellectuals who you were on
your mind that's a good question the the
60s are remembered very much of through
our projections and
not in their totalitarian their to their
totality the the um
uh the example i have in mind it is that
it was an inspiring moment in religion
particularly
the opening in the catholic church
pachamenteras
the coming of a catholic president for
the first time in the united states and
the
civil rights movement in the south
was a uh
largely a church-based movement with
heavy jewish support from the north and
the most lasting impact was
called liberation theology
which was growing
through community organizing in base
communities among the peasantry in latin
america and central america it was a
very powerful movement and for a time it
became the majority movement in the
catholic church
uh officially sanctioned in 1968 as a
matter of fact and the port hearing
statement has to be located there
there's a spirituality to the poor
hearing statement a
there's a sense of values uh there's
language that's very reminiscent of
these early
uh catholic teachings
uh uh the the linkage between
uh
you know liberation in the here and that
in the here and now as well as
uh you know in the larger scheme of of
eternity and
i don't remember the sequence but i
think
port heron came first but
there was a woman named mary varela
who became a
latina organizer around health issues
and still is in northern new mexico she
was very influential but at the time she
was with uh
the young catholic worker i think that
was the name of it
and she had some of the writings
of the church in her pocket or her purse
that she carried around with her and
people
were seen in small groups comparing
you know
the the language because we had to make
a decision on what we thought was human
nature itself
big questions yeah you don't want to
leave that out of a manifesto
and we thought that the the view of
nebor and some of the uh
you know the darker views of human
nature
uh led into a sort of political economy
that was based on fencing people in
and to
the federalist papers notion of
containing the egos and preventing
selfish interests from arising and we
thought that was counterposed to
liberation which meant
the audacity of hope shall we say good
friends and we were on that side of that
argument although of course throughout
it all i remained doubtful
of all the basics but there there was um
some
by osmosis or other means there was some
linkage between the stirrings at port
huron in that statement and what was
going on in other parts of the world
and what was going on in religious
institutions that that is uh usually
forgotten
fascinating
well the next big chapter in the the
work of tom hayden as an author is uh
your writings about uh
uh
newark
in newark you had gone to newark to
do community organizing
part of the sds
strategy
uh newark as they say exploded in 1967
right massive
unimaginable uh
uh uprising you were in the middle of
all that and the new york review asked
you to write about it
this was a 90 000 word piece which was
published in the new york review with a
very exciting
uh cover i think it's the longest piece
the new york review has ever published
in its 50-year history how did this
come to be um and and what was that
piece like my reflection is that
my writing may have changed in terms of
mellowing or deepening over 50 years but
it's it's pretty much the same
and it becomes well-known writing or
that it finds a mass outlet
only if that's useful
to the
editors of publications who are the
arbiters of
what's politically correct or culturally
interesting so
in 1967
the new york times chose to write a
column about me
that said thomas emmett hayden
pragmatic radical
uh very promising young man i guess that
meant
and so i became kind of like an icon of
the new left because all phenomenon have
to have two things a founding manifesto
and a leader
we didn't think so but that wasn't up to
us it's like
the same media establishment named the
beat generation the beat generation
they named the hippies the hippies and
so on so i was named
and then it happened that i was right in
the center of this newark uh rebellion
and violence
20 26 people killed hundreds injured and
i was one of the only people who was
again recording the whole thing i was
right there i saw people shot i talked
immediately you'd already been there for
years so i've been knocking on doors i
knew people you adonisio is a name i
remember that's right and i had access
therefore to the to the lower depths of
the ghetto
uh where most of the uh events took
place
and so i was a source a grand jury
subpoenaed me they threatened me they
tried to take my notes and i don't
remember how it went but i had a meeting
in the middle of the night with the
governor of new jersey and the leader of
the core chapter bob kervan
and we argued and negotiated to get the
troops to leave
much like vietnam
and they did leave in the morning
partial withdrawal
but for whatever for whatever reason um
i got noticed and and
i got asked by the new york review
to uh to write a piece and i sat on a
rooftop in new york and i just chopped
it out uh
a theory of how it happened and who died
and so on
no snipers um
utterly predictable and they published
the whole thing and and andy coppkind
who i think he was an editor of
something at the time
sat with me and he asked me
uh how molotov cocktails are made
and i drew one on a napkin
and he took it to the editors and they
drew
this bomb
a molotov cocktail and they put it on
the cover of this magazine so it was
this is
rebellion in newark by tom hayden and
then random house
published the whole thing as a paperback
book immediately and it was not that my
writing was any better or any worse it
was at that moment
i was the man
and
i've noticed this over 50 years where
you go like this and then
you'll rise and fall and wonder what's
happening and a lot of it i think is out
of our hands it doesn't have anything to
do with the quality of your work so what
happened with that piece
oh it's been used in special forces
training academies for the us army riot
control
who knows it's never been republished
you can get it online
but it's a standard work in the history
of urban insurrections which we've had
many of in the past century after world
war one world war ii
60s
and it was just an attempt to make sense
of why these things happen
and to argue against the notion that
they're unpredictable chaotic mob
violence with no
discernible pattern no logic to it
we wanted to say yeah there's a logic to
this because we wanted to get it over
with we wanted the troops to leave and
we had to predict the officials
that the violence would go down
that it had come to a point where it was
only the occupation by the military that
was causing the violent reaction from
the youth and if you removed the
military
the community wanted it was exhausted
they wanted to heal they wanted to they
had to go back to work they were losing
their jobs they were being thrown out of
school so the book was an attempt to
make sense of what most people
prefer to believe is like senseless
rioting
ninety thousand word piece on the cover
of the new york review books and yet you
did not become a new york review regular
i was an activist i was a leader of
anti-war and student struggles i didn't
think of myself
as wanting to be a new york review
regular i was pleased
and still am pleased
that
there was space for this eyewitness
account
it wasn't my writing necessarily it was
that i was the eyewitness
there was no other
documentation like this
i was there i was an organizer there and
i had the information on how these 20 or
25 people were killed
but i didn't get any subsequent
offers
if if anything i was uh
i don't want to sound self-pitying i was
shunned by the
new york review
and and i think it's simply because
certain people came to believe that the
new left had become too radical too far
out too sympathetic to violence
and shouldn't be encouraged it wasn't me
that put a molotov cocktail on the cover
i think they were having a flirtation
with violence i knew very well what
violence was about i i had seen it
firsthand
and uh
um
but i think i've always had that trouble
there's not there's not a lot of space
in american writing for people who
attempt to explain violence
well we need to talk about your writings
about vietnam and
the chicago conspiracy trial but first
we need to take a short break
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcast visit
booktv.org
more with tom hayden and john weiner in
a moment
retirement deficits are approaching one
trillion dollars former wall street
journal columnist roger lowenstein
argues that pension concessions like
those offered in the past by general
motors and the new york city transit
system are the cause he looks at our
current financial future and presents
steps to secure the retirement of
workers in while america aged while
america aged sunday at 5 15 pm on c-span
2's book tv
afterwards with tom hayden and john
weiner continues
when we think of the 60s of course we
think of vietnam you were one of the
key leaders of the anti-war movement you
went to vietnam at the height of the
american bombing and you wrote about
that
too
let's talk about that well that's
another example where the trip to hanoi
was an act of civil disobedience it was
technically in violation of the state
department's
laws and regulations
and there was a challenge on the table
and the the government
chose not to
try to indict us or imprison us
and
in addition to it being an act
um
it was an attempt to break
through a barrier because there had been
no coverage of vietnam nobody knew who
the enemy was
nobody knew north from south viet cong
from
uh mao zeitung and and
so
my purpose was to to write and
i went with a member of the american
communist party uh herbert aptecker
because he was able to make an
arrangement with the north vietnamese
communist party and with my friend from
civil rights days professor stoughton
lind a quaker
whose parents were sociologists and
american historians so so staunton and i
wrote a book attempting to describe what
we called the other side
and as i look at it it seems to me
uh overly romanticized but the the
purpose i think was the same
to
to bring people in this country in
connection with
the other with the
we have uh others who are always
excluded from the mainstream politics
and culture
as if they can be
uh handled
by napalming them or erasing them or
keeping us ignorant of them as opposed
to dialogue so that was the idea and
and i never would have thought that 10
years of my life would be spent
knowing vietnam
i had some kind of fatigue because i
just went back to vietnam for the first
time in 32 years wow i brought my little
boy i brought my wife
and i was in pursuit of what i called
the old revolutionaries i met uh
several people who were all in their 80s
who i had met first in 1965 just to see
how they were doing and
and how life had changed you know it's a
country that's at peace for the first
time ever
diplomatic relations with the us
uh world trade organization members
proud to have foreign investment
and the average person is about 16 or 18
years old so they're interested in the
same
gadgets and technology that our kids are
and the old revolutionaries have the
same problem of
of trying to get the kids to remember
the past
and dwell on it a little bit and learn
lessons from it and it's a very young
country
it's shocking one of the things i think
i've learned
is that while you can write accurately
and authentically and movingly
i'm not sure that i or or
many people
who attempt it are successful with their
powers of prediction
do you know what i mean it is nothing
ever turns out the way that you thought
it was going to
not vietnam not life
so the next chapter of your life is uh
chicago 68 the democratic national
convention you're one of the key
organizers of anti-war demonstrations
nixon gets elected in november
the you you are indicted uh at the begin
as soon as nixon takes office one of the
first things they do is indict you and
your
uh
fellow organizers the trial takes up a
big part of your life in a big part of
the american five years that's right but
as i understand it you didn't write
about the trial at that point as far as
i can tell at least from the tom hayden
reader it wasn't really until you wrote
your memoir reunion that you really take
on the whole issue of the trial and what
the trial was right at the time i wrote
dispatches for a
i think a defunct left-wing paper in new
york the national guardian we didn't
have we had a few underground papers
that was it
not much on
alternative radio and i did writing
again at the trial
i had the same schizophrenic experience
of being an a defendant an activist
anti-war
and i was serving as basically the third
lawyer i was constantly interviewing
witnesses and preparing the defense and
trying to analyze
how were we going to persuade the jury
and if that failed how were we going to
lay the foundation for an appeal
how were we going to succeed
in what seemed to be a very rigged uh
judicial system so
uh you were busy i was busy but the
writing was um
uh actually it may be lost i i don't
know where the
i couldn't find it but i did i did a lot
of writing on the run and then i did
some writing uh looking back of course
and it's become extremely important to
get that record straight because as you
know we're in the 40th anniversary of
this event
and um
it
soon will be on the 50th anniversary of
everything that happened in the 60s and
there's a fight going on you know was it
worth the battle should the legacy be
preserved was it all about nothing
or
will some of us be remembered so that
others
are forgotten there the approaches to
the
to memory
are not outside of the um
the field of con contestation let's say
so i think it's important we keep
engaged in the 50th anniversary
of the 60s
so that we can die a natural death
many people have tried to
kill us before uh the 60s have been
pronounced dead
but it's there it's quite alive in the
presidential campaign it's alive
everywhere so amazingly keeping
keeping some faith with what happened
and telling the stories
is just as important as it was
getting people to register to vote it
seems to me that
if their story isn't told they're still
voiceless
so next chapter vietnam war ends in 1975
the uh the movement is in complete uh
collapse uh uh at this point um
your old comrades go there different
ways this question sort of what's going
to happen now
uh
jerry rubin famously becomes a yuppie
abby hoffman
eventually gets indicted for selling
cocaine you made the decision uh rene
davis hooks up with a indian religious
uh figure
you made a different decision which was
to to
run for office in the democratic
party in california to join the
system as we called it then
this is a huge turning point in your own
political life and it also turns out in
your writing
how did you decide to take that turn
well everything gets characterized
and simplified a little bit
i mean
abby hoffman and jerry rubin and renny
davis were more than those
reductionist descriptions there was dave
dellinger who remained a lifetime
pacifist
very active
uh john freunds is a public health
specialist at ucla
bill kunsler lived on to fight many
courtroom battles len weinglas remains
one of my great friends today lee weiner
works in in public relations for
progressive causes
and and i was
i guess tagged as having entered the
system
right
and and i never thought of that uh
that way i thought of it as
it was an ex the 60s were over we had
won the big battles and that's why
there was so much confusion
the war was over the draft had been
eliminated and so on and i wanted to
know how far you could take
the citizen action and social movement
perspective into the institutions
before you were stopped was it true that
you would sell out
or not because we'd never been given the
opportunity and been banging on these
doors and it would seem a little
ridiculous if the doors opened and you
said i never wanted to enter
this place
ever anyway
so
i thought of it as an experiment
unfortunately perhaps it lasted 18 years
i was in office for a long time
and i think that this was the
sort of the responsible quote unquote
period of my life where i had a gavel
right i was chairing committees all the
time i had public policy
responsibilities
and
my writing
became a little more legalistic and a
little more
advocacy writing with a lot of pieces
published in the la times as op-eds
on genetically engineered food or
the you know orange county financial
scandal or
the saving the salmon from from
extinction uh because of
pesticide use and and uh overfishing
the
higher education becoming a racket was
so expensive that students
were being
forced out financially
all these issues
so the writing was tight it was
programmatic here's the problem here's
the solution
um
and then it was another time when i was
in demand so to speak in the marketplace
i could get op-ed pieces published all
the time i never would have imagined
that i would be in office for 18 years
but i was
until 2000.
some would say the best years of your
life
um
and the experiment was left inconclusive
well you accomplished a lot and you also
wrote a lot
you got involved uh with gangs and
thinking about gang violence at this
time this was that was the
outer perimeter of the possible remember
the early essay
i would say that i had to sacrifice
attention to
some controversial issues because there
didn't seem to be any it wasn't that i
was selling out so much as there wasn't
any traction or leverage there
so i i chose not to take up um
the
the war on drugs for example which i
think is a expensive uh
counterproductive
uh wedge issue
that that i should have taken up um
but because there was no easy
legislative solution i couldn't get a
bill out of committee i let that slide
the the exception and and i'm not quite
sure the explanation of it i think it
has to do with my roots in newark and
the south
was i couldn't abide the demonizing of
all young people as gang members all
gang members as murderers or potential
murderers
suitable only for imprisonment that led
to california being the largest
incarceration center in the united
states
and the united states
uh having 20 or 30 percent of the
world's inmates
amazing
the politics of law and order
were so successful politically that we
were
creating these huge side effects that
will be with us so i tried a lot of zany
things i hired some extra gang members
on my staff i i i tried to analyze
programs that might
help transform these young people
into
positive and constructive rebels if they
were going to be rebels as opposed to
self-destructive
and i think we had some success i think
we actually changed the minds
on the inside but but everybody thought
i was out of my mind politically that
they did not want to be tagged as soft
on gangs or
using tax dollars to hire ex-gang
members
even if they agreed privately it was for
a worthy purpose so there
i saw the limits of working within the
system
good people
but
calculating about what they had to do to
survive
and excluding certain issues all
together
as
somebody's business down the road but
not the kind of issues they wanted to
take up which meant if you didn't have
outside forces external crises
you might never get the attention of
politicians you had to make it something
that their constituencies cared deeply
about to get them
activated
you wrote a book about gangs and then
you also got involved with ireland
another place with a
history of violence
makes sense doesn't warfare
uh
your your ireland book is one of my
favorites well i got very interested in
ireland
because in the late 60s
after chicago i felt like they'd had a
lot of my american identity beaten out
of me
and i had never been raised as an irish
american
i was a i was a white young man
from the midwest and
and as the uh
identity got taken away the women took
their identity the blacks took their
identity the chicanos took theirs
what was left was uh being a white man
yeah which pretty boring
yeah it's not not promising and and so
uh at just that moment i saw on
television
the civil rights marchers in northern
ireland being hosed gassed and arrested
and they were singing we shall overcome
and and it's it had a stunning effect on
me and not a born-again experience but
stunning
stunning because i realized that this
was
a missing part of my heritage and that
they knew
more about ourselves than i knew about
them they were even borrowing and
embracing and universalizing the song we
shall overcome so i became very very
interested i didn't think
that my identity had been lost and i
could just call up lost and found and
get it back i thought it was more likely
that it was stolen
in a subtle way gradually by
my parents trying to blend in the
universities discrediting any idea of
irish civilization
and
i searched i tried to go to ireland and
i was prevented from going there because
i was seen as a revolutionary from
america
so it took me a long time
but then i i became very interested in
the beginnings of the peace process and
i renewed my old contacts
from ireland and for about 10 years i
led an
additional life besides the legislature
and family life i was
constantly involved in trying to
persuade the clinton administration to
do the right thing in northern ireland
and constantly involved in trying to
work to promote greater understanding of
how
there might be a peace deal
that could be negotiated and once and
for all uh move the island forward and
these were very very important years i
felt i was
having
useful effects but it was also quite uh
important for my
the reconstitution of who i was and i
wrote a couple of books on the irish
famine
of the 1840s and another one called
irish on the inside
it didn't get me anywhere in california
politics
i should have lived in in boston
new york chicago or san francisco but uh
in west l.a
people were just like wondering
what's with this guy yeah tom focus that
sort of thing so eventually you were
termed out of the legislature you uh
didn't get to be the mayor of la
um
1999
uh you're no longer a elected democratic
party official
there's some anti-globalization protests
i actually was i was out in 2000 but oh
you were still an elected yeah
some of my young friends
the children of the of the 60s
generation
came to me and said tom
seattle
you've got to go and what did this mean
to you well i gradually tried to
incorporate what it meant to me as a
legislator and then later in terms of
social movements what it meant as a
legislator is that the world trade
organization protocols
took away from california
sovereignty over a lot of legislative
policy
in agriculture in in pesticides and
environmentalism
anything that was considered a re a
restraint on free corporate trade
could be challenged
and i commissioned a a study and we
found there were a hundred california
laws some of which i had been very
involved in that would be on the block
if we accepted
this arrangement and these tribunals so
i went up to i went up to yes and yes
seattle and i was tear gassed i was
stuck i had no sense
of the creative militancy of this new
generation of students
i'd seen them percolating up yes in the
environmental movement but this was
really an extraordinary uh wave of
demonstrations that actually
stopped they wanted to end but they
stopped the world trade organization in
its tracks and caused
a continuing reconsideration of what
we're doing that is still reflected in
today's uh presidential debates
now i remember very effective i remember
interviewing interviewing you on the
radio
right after those demonstrations and you
were arguing at that point
these demonstrations are better than
anything we did in the 60s i think what
i said is they were bigger than chicago
yeah um and that they they had more
immediate more immediate effect in the
sense that they actually
stopped the world trade organization
uh temporarily but they stopped it from
functioning stopped it from approving
all of these onerous uh regulations
when we tried to stop segregated lunch
counters
30 years before we we did but then they
would reopen and it would be a long long
process
but in this case i thought
you know when the when the the dust
cleared and the smoke settled and the
tear gas was gone
people would look at it more clearly and
see that
that a more secretive apparatus the wto
had been exposed
and we have bought precious time for the
american people and american
institutions to consider what what is
our role in the world you know are we
trying to create a corporate empire
are we trying to roll back uh
protections on health safety environment
consumer products that were the
achievements of past generations and i
think it was very healthy the seattle
generation i'm afraid
became derailed
somewhat because of iraq so we won't
know
what the seattle generation
would have become
for that uh
brief period though it was extremely
powerful it was global
and it's still around but until iraq has
really resolved i don't think you'll
find
enough attention here
the evidence that it goes on is look at
latin america eight nine ten elections
uh to the to the presidency in countries
that used to be under dictatorships that
were considered
economic satellites of the united states
whether it's
argentina brazil venezuela uruguay
paraguay
chile the list goes on these are all
countries that have turned against
what was transpiring in seattle so it's
by no means over and i i went to many of
these places i went to the
demonstrations in miami i went to cancun
to the next effort at the wto
i went to bolivia on a couple of
occasions to investigate the rise of
a peasant movement in the election of
the first indigenous
president of that country
all very moving and interesting
experiences that reminded me of
mississippi in the beginning
but now the south was the whole global
south
and and
it seemed to me a certain
consistent pattern
from the beginning to the end of my life
at least
my life so far
your life so far for the last
five years
you've been very engaged with the iraq
war critiquing the iraq war
organizing against the iraq war and
writing about the iraq war what do you
see as the key uh the key issues in your
writing in this period well i think i
can be helpful because of my vietnam
experience that's why i chose it
it reminds me of the days during vietnam
when
there were there were moderates who said
we can't just leave
there's got to be negotiations now
and then there were people who said no
negotiations just get out
and because no one could resolve the
disagreements here
the whole business collapsed
horrifically and
americans were leaving on helicopters
and genocide was being committed in
cambodia and so on so
i do think a lot of attention has to be
paid to the
the the reason why
our government won't leave
and
more attention to
what does it take for them to be
compelled to leave i happen to think the
election of a new president
is a step but not the only step
because this president wants to continue
and
to send it on to the to the uh to the
future the the key finding is that the
the presidents the the congressional
people the the powers that be
see themselves as a superpower as an
empire as number one
and like machiavelli the reputation of
the government
the reputation of the pentagon is all
important
so
they simply are unable to consider
getting out
a businessman on the other hand might
very well say
what's wrong with cutting our losses
yeah
like
they're used to like leaving
chaos behind and starting a new
enterprise but those who represent the
united states of america with capital
letters
think that they're representing our
supremacy and so you have to find some
way
to protect their image
to the extent possible
while getting them out
and i think the will of the people as
expressed in voting
is an absolute essential but it's very
revealing that it doesn't seem to be
enough well let's talk about that a
little more uh both democratic
candidates
say they want to
draw down troops rapidly they sort of
disagree on how many how soon
what's your assessment of what what more
what more
you uh
you would like to see
well the difference between the
republicans and democrats seems clear
but as many taxi drivers have told me
you should always vote for the guy that
sounds like he's against you because
he'll turn out to be
for you so you never know really what's
going on here but there seems to be this
sharp difference keep the war going end
the war yeah but in those three words
three little words end the war
you find
hillary clinton most most of all
barack obama somewhat
uh has a
a qualifier that there has to be a
residual force for counter-terrorism
iraqis
for embedding themselves with iraqis for
advising iraqis protecting the embassy
and so on and if you total it up
you're talking between 10 and 30
thousand if you understand that there's
a three to one multiplier in terms of
the backup troops you need to support
those troops you are at fifty thousand
minimum and it begins to look like
counter insurgency in central america
not an exit from iraq
whether this is election hyperbole
whether this is reality is remains to be
seen
but but
you know my experience is that civil
society and public opinion and voters
count
if only because the politicians have to
come around every four years and they
have to
seek seek our votes
and having a mandate for peace this
november
uh just as there was a mandate for peace
in november 2006
is a very important contribution that we
can make the rest is
to find ways to compel them
to get out sooner rather than later
my
worst estimate is that it will be with
us another five or eight years
and i say that because dan ellsberg
wrote from his experience
in the pentagon and with the pentagon
papers that
the purpose of the executive branch of
the establishment
is not to lose
and so they will escalate enough
to not lose
and pass the poison pill of the war on
to the next administration
who will learn that they dare not lose
and who therefore will do whatever it
takes to keep it going to pass it on
again there has to be
an adult alternative
i would say but
i don't know who in our establishment
has the wisdom to see that this actually
is a threat to our democracy
and our standing in the world and it's
better
to
seize the diplomatic initiative
bargain with iran talk to the
neighboring countries
but it you're not going to get anywhere
unless you announce that you actually
plan to leave you're going to abandon
the occupation
the u.n isn't even going to support the
occupation after december our allies
have virtually all left
the british i think have 1500 outside an
air base
there's there's not there's no there
there and yet
the image of something there is is what
the the president is trying to promote
uh and
you'll notice the democrats are
are vague
obama's clearest 16-month withdrawal of
combat troops
but his advisers say leave 30 000 behind
well that's up to iraq my question as
from a military point of view would be
how would you do better with 30 000
americans there if you failed to win
with 150 000
these are questions to take up uh next
year
well tom i'm sorry we're out of time
thanks for talking with us today thanks
john always
[Music]